donc j'ouvre l'application wing et ensuite cela
me donne la possibilité de commander auprès de
Walgreens c'est la seule option que j'ai
en ce moment
donc j'ai deux options de livraison je peux
soit l'avoir à l'intérieur de la porte ou je peux
l'avoir sur mon allée
euh un  minute et 30 secondes, ça devrait
être ici
[Musique]
la première fois que j'ai commandé, j'ai commandé
un paquet de collations composé de chips et de bonbons
et une boisson juste pour l'essayer et voir
à quoi ça ressemblait, puis la prochaine fois
j'en avais besoin  Des pansements, j'ai donc commandé des
pansements. Je pense qu'il vaut mieux être
livré par drone plutôt que par voiture,
car
c'est très utile pour l'environnement.
puissance et ils sont également plus sûrs pour
la communauté que d'avoir de gros camions sur
nos routes et autoroutes encombrées et
des choses comme ça, mais vous savez que c'est aussi
beaucoup moins cher, donc quand vous pensez
à cela à grande échelle quand vous avez un
pilote supervisant plusieurs avions
simultanément à partir d'un  emplacement éloigné
[Musique]
merci